every game has its Superstars like right
now for it yay though
every game has players who have raised
the skill ceiling and pushed the
boundaries of what's possible The Flash
goes in sports
yay
leadable again
has one player who stands Above the Rest
behind the yellow box and yay's not
finding too much with the tour de force
in hand oh as I see that what's his name
in valorence young history only one
player has truly risen above the
competition and yay there's three can be
on for the ace if you get to Tommy right
he knows he reads it like a book yay
it's an animal in these moments but
yay's Journey to the top of valorent
wasn't an easy one I kind of like ran
into like a situation in which like I
was dealing with like a lot of like
mental health and related stuff this is
the story of the best player valorent
has ever seen this is the story of yay
[Music]
foreign
Jacob yay Whitaker always loved FPS
games from the moment his father
introduced him to Medal of Honor yea was
hooked on Shooters growing up in Fort
Wayne Indiana there just wasn't much
else for a kid like him to do so yay
often spent his spare time playing video
games but it was when he discovered Call
of Duty that yay got his first real
taste of competition unlike most Cod
players yay played the game with a
keyboard and mouse and his skills were
so impressive many players actually
thought that he was cheating yeah at
least in like the whole like Call of
Duty scene
um the only anti-cheat was like back and
like all the guys were like convinced
like absolutely like convinced I was
like cheating and I remember even like
vividly like uh we were like playing a
game I was just having that I was having
a series I was like spamming people
through walls like I don't know it's
like a really good game for me and my
own team actually ended the game and
they kicked me out and they're just like
yeah cheating isn't cool dude I'm
I'm like all right
after getting kicked from his amateur
Call of Duty roster yay needed a new
game to play and that's when he fell in
love with cs go yay quickly Rose through
the semi-pro ranks grinding his way
through face it an esea and eventually
making it to rank s but once he got
there yay encountered a bit of a setback
this wasn't my first time being it the
there was a there was like a situation
before where I joined like rank yes and
FPL and got kicked prior uh mainly
because uh I think at the time I was at
my mom's place and I was getting like
I had the worst Internet available but I
still wanted to play like a whole bunch
so I got kicked out even after getting
kicked from FPL yay was determined to
make it big in CS despite his internet
woes some top n a Pros were willing to
vouch for him and in July 2017 yay
finally got that shot he signed with
complexity and once he made his debut on
csgo's biggest stage yay made sure not
to waste the opportunity the bomb will
at least go down on something great shot
from yay double with the awp this is
trying to run on Vega very quickly and
that's a big problem they need to win
this round they've done everything right
up until the last couple of seconds here
Android
the opening frag and taking down [__]
and crushes in the middle of nowhere you
can tell he's gonna go down to yay what
a turn around a quad kill from yay his
job to turn this corner immediate dinky
is ready for the next one as well he
gets that too and now how do you get
this bomb Planet Scout from above
tagging you and there's the peak yay
quad killing the round 11-7 in
complexity they do it right back well
this bomb plant isn't even gonna go down
and yay's done it who better to close it
out complexities top eight finish at the
London major shocked everyone it was an
amazing accomplishment for a relatively
new roster but although yay had a lot to
be proud of he was already starting to
feel burnt out I would say like during
my time with complexity or like towards
like the end I kind of like ran into
like a situation in which like I was
dealing with like a lot of like mental
health kind of related stuff and I would
say like like especially like after the
London major instead of like I I would
say like taking like a break you know
and like taking like a week or two off
or like two or three weeks kind of like
the solution and this this wasn't by
Stan's law but kind of like upper
management was like Hey we're on the hot
streak let's keep going you know and
like the whole time I spent like over
like a month or two in like Europe so I
my my mental health like I started
getting like really like burnt out of
the game in the months that followed
yay's performance started to slip as he
struggled with his mental health by the
end of 2018 he was benched which only
made things worse I just remember like
for like over two weeks I was like kind
of like depressed in bed like I could
not leave my bed like whatsoever it was
it was a rough time yay ultimately
decided to stick to CES but after losing
his spot on complexity all he could do
was hop between various tier two rosters
and just when he thought he had finally
found a place to call home yay's entire
world came crashing down
during the pandemic tons of North
American orgs pulled out of
Counter-Strike and it became painfully
clear that the game was no longer a
viable career option for someone like
yay so in April 2020 he jumped ship to
valorent I smoke
like Ice Bike
Dude one enemy remaining
that's one here
yay quickly got scooped up by and box
and began competing in valorence
burgeoning Pro scene where he steadily
built a reputation as one of Na's
deadliest Duelists and he earned a
pretty badass nickname too wait this
team is actually oh my God
himself
one enemy remaining
oh [__] boys when you see him alive even
though he's one HP and he's won before
you're like maybe he can win this like
you're like yeah
it's just a meme to me you know like
just like everyone talks about like
ranked demons and then like some people
are like this is like the action you
know the re the demon above all things
you know kind of thing El Diablo was
considered one of the most lethal frag
artists in North America and his
performance in matchmaking translated to
officials but there was one huge problem
his team just couldn't keep up it's
gonna be so difficult right now zetting
with a takedown Mata through the cage
they build that backside control the
other important backlight control and
they got numbers it's up to Vice against
three to try to make this one work but
it really seems like a nightmare and
indeed hey I'm gonna have to wake up
right now because the nightmare is over
for now as cloudline clinch it he's down
on Mikhail still around the corner still
hasn't spotted him finally catches off
the arm Sean's still in the back line
there you go he has no clue that
somebody is in B name but he doesn't
even go for it he waltzes on by half the
diffuse has gone in but Mikhail runs on
in suffs the barrel and Genji have
qualified for the close qualifier yay
was putting up insane numbers but it
wasn't enough to carry and box across
the finish line again like I had like
these goals and like these expectations
and things like I want to do and like if
we're not like if we're not moving
forward if we're just like people aren't
like willing to give it their all like
it's just like it's kind of like a
situation which like I don't wanna I
don't want to be a part of that
environment once yay showed interest in
leaving and box a bidding war reportedly
broke out but in the end he chose Envy
Envy were already considered one of the
best teams in N A but they were missing
one thing they didn't have a true
dedicated jet Opera which made yay the
perfect fit
made his Mark immediately helping Envy
qualify for their first ever
International Event and once he finally
had his chance to represent n a on the
international stage El Diablo showed
everyone what the world had been missing
one bullet left for my mind if he's able
to get that all right he's good for one
it's gonna be on to steal he has to
creepers
keep his word a Red Bull clutch from yay
Envy went all the way to the Grand
finals without dropping a single map
cementing themselves as the absolute
best team in N A but they weren't the
best team in the world Gambit was just
too strong I mean oh my God yeah he's
made a meal of it
yay came so close to lifting his first
International trophy with Envy but
despite the heartbreaking loss he was
optimistic about the future obviously
you know giving to the Grand finals is
like amazing but I'm just more happy
that like we at least like so far we're
like we're continually like getting
better and I think it's like as long as
you're constantly like working to get
better like the results are like a
byproduct of that heading into Champions
the final event of the Year hopes were
high for Envy yea was poised to improve
on that second place finish at Masters
Berlin but Champions didn't exactly go
as planned and let's get the first one
Victor can you get the trade he can one
versus one Victor for Envy but it's Zeke
who pulls it out of the bag in his sand
get the defuse they're moving to the a
site Cruise we'll try to hold on he gets
away with three the lockdown will do
absolutely nothing the stun to the back
side oh they're gonna eliminate Sushi
Boy to start with my body is still going
strong in the backside down through the
cloudburst and here comes the blade
storm but it's not even needed scary
closes it out an SCA are going all the
way to playoffs Envy collapsed at the
biggest Tournament of the Year yay ended
the season looking for Revenge after a
performance so bad it tarnished his
otherwise impeccable record but luckily
during the off season Riot released a
new agent an agent that seemed like it
was designed specifically for yay
[Music]
chamber was a killing machine his
ultimate was a free operator with an
absurd rate of fire and his Headhunter
ability basically gave him a pocket
Guardian to use on eco rounds that meant
Yay who already had disgusting aim and
was a god with the op could use chamber
to his full broken potential
oh no absolute catastrophe as yay it
finds perfect time
annihilates the entire team secures the
ace Envy now playing as optic entered
Masters Reykjavik 2022 ahead of the meta
they were one of the only teams who had
truly Incorporated chamber into nearly
every one of their team comps and thanks
to yay they popped off there should not
seeming to mind the approach as we see
the Tour De Forest the tour de force is
working he's already got four as a
chance bike down and one more yeah he's
not finding too much with the Toyota
force in half who as I say that what's
his name
in your hands optic on the Virgin it's
over it's overdone optic gaming build
their legacy brick fine break yay
finally had his trophy he dominated the
event with insane stats and some of the
sickest plays of the event by the time
Masters 1 was over everyone knew his
name now you have this trophy in your
hands how does it feel
s good
don't don't you do me like that describe
your emotions for me oh
yeah it's pretty great it's pretty good
we are taking a brief pause from your
regularly scheduled story of programming
to bring you from the Undisputed goat of
valorent to the Undisputed goat of FPS
monitors
and mice
and most paths I'm talking about zowie
look if you're a competitive FPS player
you know that when it comes to improving
to being the best of the best it can all
come down to milliseconds to seeing your
opponent just that Split Second sooner
than they see you the point is you too
can give yourself a leg up with zowie's
XL 2566k monitor this thing is literally
as good as it gets it features zowie's
patented diac plus technology basically
it controls how and when backlighting is
turned off and on at specific points in
the TN panel which functionally reduces
motion blur and the after images you
hate to see in other monitors the bottom
line is that this stuff is massively
noticeable seriously zowie sent me both
the 240 hertz and a 360 Hertz to try out
and sponsorship and fanboyism aside I am
in love with them once you've tried diac
plus there's no going back they are
pricey but if you are serious about FPS
you should definitely give them a whirl
despite the highs optic experienced in
Iceland by the time the next
International Event rolled around yay
seemed shakier sure the team was showing
up domestically but in Copenhagen El
Diablo had a slow start finds one life
in them yet and even situation his zip
and going back around
[Applause]
all of them to do it and fpx will make
it to the Grand finals
after the team's disappointing resultant
Masters optic entered Champions with a
lot to prove they were the best in n a
one of the best teams in the world but
yay needed to show up if the team wanted
to win and luckily in Istanbul El Diablo
looked Unstoppable
but there it is that's what you needed
he plays ahead of the timing finds
Leicester flying close by and he's still
doing this he has to be the protagonist
what's that a completely unaware and yay
this three could be on for the ace if he
gets to Tommy right he knows he reads it
like a book yay it's an animal in these
moments just one more and it looks so
good with you all through Champions yay
was a statistical freak of nature
topping the server in just about every
game he played but he wasn't just
receiving praise for his fragging power
while some players tend to overheat
after getting an opening pick yay knew
when to be aggressive and when to sit
back and rely on his positioning his
performance in Istanbul helped prove
that he was one of the smartest players
in valorant and his dominance helped
optic to their third Grand Final at an
International Event more than any other
team in valorence young history I mean
he's already beaten everybody else as
far as tournament performances is going
and this is a tournament he has beaten
himself to move the marker up higher and
higher with every single appearance just
what an incredible player but although
yay and optic were dreaming of lifting
the Champions Trophy awaiting them in
the finals was their biggest rival loud
optic and Loud faced off more than any
other two teams throughout 2022 and all
of their battles culminated in one final
meeting that would decide who would take
home the game's most prestigious trophy
none of us sort of saw this round good
for oh my
oh Mike Victor none the wiser first of
all the dragon
[Applause]
ball
I've now seen as well so telling at this
time the rest of the team is on the way
through caves are just so well punishing
it oh can you believe it needs to stay
cool and he's done well with one but
it's not gonna be enough as Saucy now in
the 1v2 the longer to come in but they
are closing the Gap faster safe plan but
then Ellis players are long
note the one closer garage he absolutely
has and with 40 HP
it's all on one the last man standing at
finesse and after so much time so many
years of operation at the hands of optic
loud beat them in the best possible way
loud got their Revenge that day and
although it wasn't the ending yay was
hoping for he still had a lot to be
proud of he cemented himself as the best
player in the world he helped make OpTic
the most consistent valorant roster the
world has ever seen and even though
they've since gone their separate ways
yay and the rest of that iconic roster
made history together
during the off season everyone wondered
where yay would end up with optic
missing out on franchising it was only a
matter of time before someone came in
and scooped him up in the end yay
decided to fulfill one of his lifelong
dreams he took his services to one of
Na's most storied orgs Cloud9 uh what
got me to Cloud9 was mainly
uh at least when we always played you on
optic and when I was still a part of
optic you guys were probably one of the
most challenging teams especially in
North America Cloud9 have built a super
team they're one of the deadliest
rosters in the America region bolstered
by yay the best player in the world with
the VCT landscape changing in 2023
Cloud9 are the ones to watch out for but
no matter what happens next yay has
already left his Mark as one of the
greatest players valorent has ever seen
and as far as we can tell he's just
getting started
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for a unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock